meanwhile one of the few things we know
about the fbi's right on mar-a-lago is
that it involves classified
documentation the national archive
claims the documents belong to them
president trump's attorneys were
reportedly already complying with the
fbi on these documents earlier this year
as late as june
so why did merrick go an approval
warrant for the raid lara trump joins us
right now
laura could you bring us through the
week that you and your family have had
from monday's raid to today's presser
well this is not the week we planned uh
brian i can tell you that but you know
unfortunately i think a lot of us in the
trump family have gotten used to this
kind of treatment um you know we have
been targeted we have been harassed i
would say that donald trump is probably
the most harassed investigated president
in american history
you think that with all that they're
doing and you just talked about the new
york attorney general you have you know
district attorneys in manhattan you have
obviously this raid at mar-a-lago if up
until this point for the past almost
seven years that donald trump has been
harassed and investigated that there was
anything to find on donald trump you
think it wouldn't have been found by now
i mean he ran a clean company he had a
great business he still has a great
company run by my husband um but this
sort of thing obviously is not easy to
go through as a family but it's not easy
to go through as an american and i can
tell you that i've heard from so many
people brian all across this country
people that aren't even republicans they
are horrified by what we saw happen on
monday because this was not just an
attack on donald trump it wasn't just a
raid of mar-a-lago of a former
president's home this changed the way
that the american people see our country
we cannot operate in a civilized society
and not trust our department of justice
unfortunately that's where we are
merrick garland came out today and
didn't clear any of that up if anything
we have more questions now
the american people by and large than
they did a couple hours ago before he
even came out and spoke so what's
interesting is too those two attorneys
who have which we've seen a lot on the
air in various podcasts and television
networks including one and on jessie's
show they weren't even allowed inside
they would sit outside it was about 98
degrees in florida and they sat outside
for the eight nine hours trying to get
an understanding of what exactly is
happening what's the premise and
predicate behind it and i happened to
talk to eric on monday and i could not
believe how cool and con and cool and
calculated he was how angry he is but
almost saying look it this is what i'm
dealing with on a regular basis but what
i also found is i was watching the bbc
and sky news
they can't make heads or tails of it
they're asking our reporters what's
going on in america and i kind of worry
about that beyond this administration
beyond the past administration do you
i mean i think everyone is worried about
it i think that um we don't see the
country that we used to know right now
this this sort of political harassment
and targeting
these are things that happen in
communist countries and third world
dictatorships not in the united states
of america and i don't know how you come
back from this even if my father-in-law
decides to run and wins in 2024 which i
believe if he decides to run he will win
how do you re how do you assure the
american people at any point that you've
gotten this taken care of that you can
that the department of justice is
something they can trust again i don't
know but i can tell you this
people are fired up out there in the
first couple of hours after this was
announced brian the fundraising to
re-elect donald trump has been more than
since the day he left office people want
him back and they want him back as soon
as possible so let's read this together
the washington post has just crossed
with this story
they believe the reason why the raid
took place is because they were worried
that
your father-in-law had documents related
to nuclear weapons among the items the
fbi wanted back experts in classified
information said the unusual search
underscores deep concern among
government officials about the types of
information they thought could be
located at trump's mar-a-lago club did
you see any nuclear reports at the
mar-a-lago club maybe around the pool by
the lifeguard stand
yeah no those were not uh disseminated
freely at mar-a-lago of course not um
but
i mean who knows by the way i think it's
a mystery to a lot of people what could
possibly rise to the level of not taking
a a bit of a different approach and
instead raiding the former president's
home i mean i i it's just absolutely
outrageous brian this is not the country
that that we've come to know and love
for for so long and lastly this it and
you know they'll expand on this story
but i saw there's a report out there
that ivarka milani won up to the
president said listen i've had enough
don't run again could you tell me if
that is indeed the case is there a sense
within the family that it's just getting
too much
i can tell you that every single member
of our family if we uh wanted him to run
before which we are all happy to support
him we want him to do it even more now
because somebody has got to take this
country back somebody has got to restore
faith in america and i think the only
person to do that quite frankly is
donald trump lara trump i'll talk to you
again thanks so much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight